macht am besten mit eurem seitensprung
bestimmte uhrzeiten und
das ist ein geheimdienst level herzlich
kommt sondern die leute bei dem ich mich
das muss ich in aller deutlichkeit
wirklich so sagen schon fast schäme dass
ich bis dato keine action dazu gemacht
habe es ist ein video von bibi ist ein
altes video von baby und ist ein sehr
bekanntes video eigentlich sogar für
mich hat das bisher nur dato gar nicht
auf dem radar aber auch vor zu von einer
zuschauerin auf instagram hinweis darauf
bekommen und deswegen machen wir heute
dieses video leute es geht um ein video
von babyartikeln ist aus dem jahr 2012
in dem sie tipps gibt wie man einen
seitensprung also dass betrügen in einer
beziehung verheimlicht vorne wäre wenn
man diese videos reinziehen wir müssen
halt ich berücksichtigen dass das video
acht jahre alt ist wir können jetzt
sagen hast oder gesagt heute wenn man
acht jahre alte videos von mir hätte
dann würde ich da wirklich die
abstrusesten sachen drin sagen also muss
man auch ein bisschen fern das angehen
das video ist ja sie war damals deutlich
ging also wenn wir nicht alles auf die
goldwaage legen also schon aber halt nur
in einem lustig gemeinten sind nicht im
sinne von ernster kritik und haben
allgemein leute das ist einfach zu bild
das ist ein bbb von bbb wie tipps gibt
wie man fremd geht der audi passen die
zwei welten zusammen wir schauen jetzt
einfach mal rein
hallo video gebe ich euch ein paar tipps
für eure seitensprung verein könnt also
das passt wirklich nicht zusammen das
spricht eigentlich für baby leute oder
das spricht für sie wie wir hat sich
wirklich ein image aufgebaut wo man ihr
als person niemals never ever zutrauen
würde dass sie so etwas machen würde
tolerieren würde ich muss sagen ich habe
es wie auch besagt aber nicht gesetzt
ich kenne auch den background dazu nicht
ob das irgendwie am ende aufgelöst wird
was genau ist der kontext dafür ist oder
ob es wirklich einfach nur das ist
wonach es aussieht dass sie einfach
ernst gemeinte tipps gibt weiß ich hier
ziemlich das erste ist dass wir
natürlich das ist schon geil das
unterstreicht schon direkte punkt den
ich gerade schon gemacht hat heute e
mail adresse e mail
also wie gesagt dieses video ist alt
stammt aus einer zeit wo man kontakt mit
menschen aus seinem privaten umfeld
freundin dates wort erst einmal per
e-mail gehalten hat das ungefähr so mit
zeitraum gewesen sein wo die dinosaurier
noch gelebt haben also immer jetzt so
wirklich wild wird ich habe letztens
optik doch was gesehen dass wirklich zu
krank da hat einfach irgendein typ mit
all seinem seinem seitensprung sich von
anfangs nur das video ist mit seinem mit
der person mit der fremdgegangen ist
einfach über playstation network
geschrieben von der playstation gibt so
nachrichtendienst darüber geschrieben
aber es ist trotzdem aufgeflogen
eure seitensprungs auf jeden fall unter
einem falschen namen leute wir müssen
ich will das noch betont haltet euch das
vor augen dieses video ist von der
gleichen person gemacht die web gemacht
hat die iks millionen mit wie du
verdient hat die allen der erfolgreichen
youtube in deutschland ist also ops ließ
das video nicht mehr auf ihrem kanal ist
ja klar aber es ist das schon das ist
schon okay heute kurzer kuba ist jetzt
leider schon später machen weiter mit
dem video das soll hier nicht nach aber
das ist doch einfach absurd oder also
was da für eine kriminelle energie in
diesen tipps trennen ist das irgendwie
schon fast ein alter dazu dieser
hintergrund das ist einfach so ein
gegensatz zu der ultra professionellen
perfekt produzierten business baby die
man sonst von youtube kenntnisse zu geil
was kommt als nächstes
ja also besorgt ihr verschiedene handys
diverse sim-karten und wenn irgend
jemanden wind davon bekommt das den
seitensprung hat ist
passen verschwinden bringt warum denn
über handy kontakt mit auf seiten halten
reichstädter solltet ihr auf jeden fall
darauf achten dass er nicht übermäßig
die ganze zeit nehmen
das ist natürlich auch schneide das ist
das ist wirklich schlau das ist vor
allem auch ein link sehr intelligenter
und auch komplexer tipp da war ich
selbst noch nicht drauf gekommen
es ist angeblich weil ich kann das ja
der gedanke ich nachvollziehen es soll
nur von vorteil sein wenn man neben
seinem aktuellen offiziellen partner
nicht mit der person schreibt die mit
dem man seinen partner betrogen hat okay
da welches nicht aufgekommen
das ist ja geheimdienst level
das ist sicher dass du vorne lief
karriere nicht agentin beim bnd war es
beim bundesnachrichtendienst dem
geheimdienst von deutschland bist du dir
ganz sicher genau leute und wenn ihr
dann mit einem crash schreibt dann habe
ich euch hier jetzt mal ein
hochkomplexes verschlüsselungsprotokoll
entwickelt das auf der enigma maschine
basiert die im zweiten weltkrieg
eingesetzt wurde ich hab das ganze in
jahrelanger arbeit in meinem keller
zusammen mit dem besten mathematiker der
welt weiter entwickelt ich packe sie
einfach mal als download und eine
beschreibung
merkel so den gegensatz die switch so
zwischen den krassesten geheimdienst
techniken der welt und einfach so lass
deinen aktuellen partner nicht aufs
handy schauen wenn du deinem buch
schreibt also werden wir das ganze erst
wirklich ist einfach absurd es aber
absolut feindlichen geheimnis ja keiner
sein also wenn du bnd-agent bianca hein
ihr gewiss kann es ja immer sein dass
ich mal vom kgb vom russischen geheimnis
sogar vom mossad vom israelischen
geheimdienst einfach kommt und dich
observiert bei einem seitensprung es
kann immer sein deswegen leute mit
denken nicht in der öffentlichkeit nur
in sicheren häusern also ich mir dieses
video rausgesucht habe ich glaube dass
es auf so einem geheimdienst level
eskaliert daran scheitern tatsächlich
die meisten beziehungen das schon wieder
der russische geheimdienst sich ein
meldet wenn jenny aus bergisch gladbach
und markus aus leverkusen eine affäre
wohl jenny ihren freund peter in berge
stadtbad noch hat es ist wirklich nervig
wenn der russische militär geheimdienst
nicht involviert und die ganze scheiße
auflegen ich jetzt mal wieder auf 20
level wie wär's mit lightswitch immer
abwechselnd immer kgb steht und dann 20
keine kleine klub strecken ja keine
kritik ist big brain tipp auf jeden fall
also was soll ich dazu sagen da kann
jemand sitzt oder machen
so sollte jeder sein dass man keine
knutschfleck also man sollte allgemein
zuschauer sein dass man nicht ran gehen
oder einfach nicht in der beziehung ist
man das gefühl fremd gehen zu müssen so
aber ja keine überdimensionierten
bluterguss am hals zu haben von der
größe eines pferdefuß der darauf
hindeutet dass man fett ab und wurde ist
auch von vorteil
[Musik]
also es ist wirklich wie gesagt das ist
ein altes video wir können jetzt das
nicht auf die heutige projizieren
insofern muss man den leuten gegenüber
auf jeden fall seien leute aber es ist
wirklich eine gewisse kriminelle energie
hier in diesem video drin
das muss ich allen ernstes sagen also
dieses das level an so vorausahnend und
die wahrheit zu vertuschen ist schon ich
finde das hat schon ein bisschen was
kriminelles oder bin ich der einzige
schreibt sondern den kommentar eines
finster dabei und natürlich sollte ja
das ist kriminell
das ist so kriminell ja ich kann
wirklich auf dieses video nicht mehr
einfach eine acht jahre mindestens acht
jahre wahrscheinlich sogar noch jüngere
baby die einfach so es ist gefühlvoll
den kriminellen weiter
wie bist du eigentlich liebst du dies
gibt oder und hier ist ja einfach so ja
heute bin ich zurück mit den top fünf
tipps wie man leute die gegen einen
aussagen wollen verschwinden lässt also
ich kann natürlich nur ein zeuge hatte
dieses video hat mich wirklich straight
geschockt vielen vielen dank an die
zuschauer nehmen das auch wieder
eingesammelt hat liegt hier ein
vorgeschlagen das video ohne fremde
tipps abonniert hier um einen kanal mir
nicht fremd zu gehen bleibt stabil
gebiet nicht fremd heute macht's gut